ガンとわざとゆっくり行くんだって
こわっ
なかなかそういう風にできない
あ、そうか、これどこで回るの?
えー、やっぱりおじいちゃん優しいもんね
そう、おじいちゃんはとても優しいから
ねえ、これ曲がれないよね?そこで回ってはいけないんだよね?
え、曲がっていいんだと思う
え、ここ左曲がるじゃん
左行った方がいい?
うん、それでもう一回左やったら言えたみたいなことになる
大丈夫かな?
うん、大丈夫、大丈夫
うまい、うまい
左行ってもう一回左行ったって同じじゃない?
同じに出てきちゃうだからどうしたらいいんだ
今、右の端から出ようかと思ったんだけど
左来ちゃったらどうしよう
あ、じゃあ一回左行って
このあのー、なんていうの、立橋じゃなくて
上のあれの下を通って回ってくればいいのね
うん
どっかで右に曲がってね
いつも歩いてくるの?ここまで?オリンピックまで?
ううん、えっと一回来たときあれ、自転車
ああ、そうか
うん、いや、そんなに遠くなかったやつやった
そう、ここで左に行ってしょうがないから
こんなとこで右に曲がれなそうだから
パパも小さい、かわいい車買えばいいのに
あんまりあんないい、あのー、外車じゃなくていいのにね
すごい
ここ入っちゃいけないって書いてある?
うん
ね、これいけないんだよね、入っちゃう
あれ、じゃあどこで、どこで回っていいの?
この次で
この辺で回っとけばよかった
なかなか今度回れなくなって、帰れなくなって
ちょっと遠くまで行っちゃう
ね、ほんとだ、どうしたらいい?
うーんと、一回回るから
ほんと、ここに出ちゃったじゃない、そしたら
うん、えっと、次の左
一回まっすぐ行っても帰れる、わかる?
うん、そこ、ここ回るじゃん
左?
うん
それでね
それで、どうしたらいいかな?
それでもう一回、左に曲がって
というか、デッドエンドじゃないところ
見つけられる
でも、もう一回左に曲がったらまた同じじゃない?
右に行かなきゃダメなんじゃない?
えっと、ここ、ちょっと待って
ここさ、あの大きい道路に出たら
それとも、ただここずっとまっすぐ行けば大丈夫だと思う
それで、あの坂のさ、一番下のところにさ、あのー
大きいあれ、信号とかあるじゃん、そこでまた左が
なんだかちょっとまずいね、失敗したね
いやいや、大丈夫、大丈夫
急いでるわけでもないし
それでも、ここって全然、面々どこだかわかんない
そう